depuis le mois de mars manon gold share
n'a plus personne pour donner les soins
à ses deux fils de 23 et 28 ans ça prend
quelqu'un est clos changer les couches
qui vont faire la toilette qui va donner
les bains qui vaut fallait le
déshabillage à bien les ors de soins à
domicile sont couvertes par le programme
chèque emploi service mais la famille ne
trouve tout simplement pas de préposé
dans sa région
les jeunes ne sont vraiment pas
intéressé à venette réveillé au salaire
qu'on donne qui est là on sait plus
qu'on sait quoi faire on sait plus à qui
demander comment faire pour avoir ce
personnel qualifié l'élan du balad au
nord ont une déficience intellectuelle
ou si donc le trésor mais en réalité
c'est comme un enfant de deux ans il ya
des soins médicaux complexes c'est donc
un gavage les diabétiques au cours des
derniers mois nathalie richard a dû
remplacer deux préposés pour son fils ce
programme loge justement permet à ces
gens lieu de rester à la maison et de
désengorger système plus de 13000
personnes reçoivent de l'aide à domicile
en embauchant elles mêmes leurs préposés
grâce au programme chèque emploi service
mais la pandémie est venue accentuer la
difficulté de trouver et de garder ses
employés à montréal 16 et 40 cartes de
leur si elles partent ses employés leur
en ch et celle des faire le même travail
ces 26 $ dollars il ya eu un recrutement
pour proposant ch et celle des et on a
très peur que les gens qui se paye
l'information ce soit des gens qui
travaillaient avant pour l'amazone
chèque emploi service mais encore l'on
n'est pas capable d'obtenir les stats
c'est le cabinet du nouveau ministre de
la santé christian dubé nous dit que le
taux horaire des préposés ou chèque
emploi service sera bonifié de 12 pour
cent comparativement à 5 l'an dernier
sans toutefois préciser la date d'entrée
en vigueur de ces toros c'est
insuffisant
10 les groupes de soutien pour nous un
travail égal mérite un salaire égal donc
que le service soit de lancer hcdh
auxois donne admis
longtemps que ça va pas bien et ch et
celle d'aimer ça fait des décennies
aussi qu'on parle que soutient domicile
ne va pas bien je vois le succès que
j'ai puis j'aime la relation j'ai pu
créer avec david marine compte bien
garder son emploi pendant qu'elle étudie
pour un emploi étudiant je sais bien
pays mais pour un emploi de télé
sauvegarde qui ont des enfants puis
maison un pays tout je pense que si les
pays dit il david peut donc encore
compter sur elle mathé demain 8 heures
le matin m comme ce matin ici anne
louise despatie radio canada montréal